cinéaste aussi à saint tropez on tourne
en ce moment même depuis le début
septembre un nouveau film sur le célèbre
gendarmes
cette fois c'est le gendarme et les
extraterrestres louis de funès michel
galabru
les deux patrons de la célèbre brigade
de saint tropez pour le cinéma
sans donc confrontés aux soucoupes
volantes et aux extraterrestres mais
pour faire rire pour que les cascades en
voiture semble drôle des cascadeurs
prennent des risques et quelquefois le
destin est là pour transformer en
tragédie
ce qui n'était que comédie vous le savez
il y a eu un accident lors du tournage
de ce film une cascadeuse a raté un
virage a foncé sur la foule des badauds
et l'accident a fait hélas deux morts et
sept blessés
mais au cinéma comme au cirque la loi du
spectacle exige de continuer et ceux
d'entre vous qui ont aimé les précédents
gendarme de saint tropez et qui iront
voir le nouveau de funès mise en scène
par jean giraud n'auront à coeur que de
rire et c'est bien le but du film
tout commence par une nuit de romance
louis de funès et maria bobin roucoule
sur une colline des hauteurs de saint
tropez
mais tout va aller très vite car les
extraterrestres sont déjà là des
extraterrestres qui prennent l'apparence
des terriens et louis de funès gendarmes
sera confronté un louis de funès
extraterrestre lui ressemblant comme un
frère et le célèbre brigadier dans
quelques secondes va avoir sans doute la
plus grande surprise de sa vie
fuyons c'est un compte unique rend
l'équipe ultra
monter cet escalier le jeu cruchot
chef vous êtes l'un chefs c'est une
soucoupe qui atterrit ya pas longtemps
un louis da constaté alors nous sommes
rentrés déjà dedans une fois pas très
rassurée et enfin vous avez vu que ça
existe alors qu'est ce qui arrive à ce
gendarme de saint tropez qui après avoir
chassé les jolies filles aux seins nus
et qui après avoir chassé l'héroïne à
new york que maintenant chasse la
soucoupe volante
eh bien vous savez que maintenant
chasser la femme nue n'est ce pas mme
ochir louis est une chose vraiment
valable partout par conséquent c'est
inefficace
alors maintenant ils les gendarmes sont
confrontés aux ovnis et et tous ceux qui
vont rentrer un jour l'abri maintenant
au hasard et
il faut deux plus en plus de courage
parce que la rencontre avec tony et une
chose justement dangereuse n'est ce pas
mon cher c'est que les extraterrestres
dans notre fils sont très très très très
gentil et nous entrons terriens que nous
sommes nous ne pensons qu'une chose à
les détruire et bien sûr ne sont très
charmant alors à quoi les reconnaîtrons
ces extraterrestres il sonne creux
si on fait ça ça sonne creux voilà vous
savez que pour venir pour en somme de
comment dirais-je mystifié ils ont pris
notre apparence par conséquent ne pas
bien qu'on a eu en louis de funès
descendants quand même et enfin moi
c'est plus modeste mais quand même
louis de funès descendra du ciel c'est
un magnifique cadeau mais en fer blanc
quand même c'est alors n est pas mon
cher oui mais voilà le gendarme et les
extraterrestres sortira sur les écrans
au mois de février dans quatre mois